long lines in downtown Oakland Kamala
Harris drew a big crowd here for her
campaign kickoff rally among them many
young women like Island Portugal eager
to hear what the senator has to say we
really love how strong she is in like
criminal justice reform immigration
she just doesn't allow people to bully
her like she asked the hard questions
she keeps her composure she's really
well-spoken I am excited to see her
share her platforms and speak about what
matters and ultimately be reinvigorated
by her yeah this rally was supposed to
be a show of political force and it
certainly looked that way when Kamala
Harris took to the stage the daughter of
Jamaican and Indian immigrants promised
to be a fighter for the people stating
that it was time to restore what she
views as the loss of American values
under President Trump we are here
because the American Dream and our
American democracy are under attack and
on the line like never before and we are
here at this moment in time because we
must answer a fundamental question who
are we who are we as Americans let's
answer that question America we are
better than this the Democratic Party is
looking for fresh faces and Kamala
Harris who's been a US Senator for only
two years certainly fits that bill she
grew up here in Oakland a diverse
industrial city known for its toughness
high crime rates and political left-wing
activism now she is the first female
black candidate having a viable shot at
the presidency but with dozens of
Democrats lining up to run in 2020 the
crucial question will be whether the
party thinks Kamala Harris has a chance
of beating Donald Trump her supporters
definitely think she does
she understands people she understand
the middle class she understand the
needs of our country and she has morals
which we don't have right now with a
year and a half until the Democrats
picked her presidential nominee Kamala
Harris still has a long way to go but
her Oakland rally was beyond doubt a
good start